on a weekend where we expected to look
back at her remarkable reign the monarch
had other ideas
using this moment to intervene on the
question of whether camilla should be
queen her message to the nation clear
when in the fullness of time my son
charles becomes king she writes i know
you'll give him and his wife camilla the
same support that you've given me
and it's my sincere wish that when that
time comes camilla will be known as
queen consort as she continues her own
loyal service
since they married in 2005 it's been a
controversial topic as the public blamed
her for the breakdown of his marriage to
princess diana royal aides said camilla
didn't want to be queen and intended to
be known instead as princess consort but
the questions have continued about
whether that would actually be the case
with a lot of people in the wake of
princess steiner's death
all those years ago that camilla wasn't
that popular over time i think she's
proved her
herself as a great dedicated servant not
only to the crown but also working
alongside prince charles on the world
stage and supporting him in all the work
that he does
doing up to 200 engagements a year she
certainly settled into what's expected
from royal life
a close working team the prince clearly
grateful for her support
for a long time it's been suspected that
when prince charles becomes king he
would automatically want to make camilla
his queen but endorsement from his
mother who is so widely respected in
this country and right around the world
could not be more powerful especially on
a weekend when minds are so focused on
that matter of succession
in the ballroom at sandringham the queen
could not have seemed on better form at
the first proper event for her platinum
jubilee i did remark that it was upside
down and you wouldn't be able to see
what was on it i thought it had to be
upside down for the pressure
[Laughter]
a chance to meet up with old friends
including a catch-up with other members
of the wi you've had a very sort of a
darn time
i'm afraid yeah
kobe doesn't help
yvonne brown has been the vice president
since the 1990s
obviously it's a special day and
i think she enjoyed it and i think it
was equally i think it was good for her
to see some of the people from the local
area and be able to chat to them about
normal things
there was also a reminder of other big
occasions angela woods helped create the
original recipe for coronation chicken
in 1953.
please don't try one if you'd like to
see
i'll go away
to come and have an invitation like that
from her and i was told it was a
personal invitation
i feel you know really honored
the only british monarch to reach a
platinum jubilee she's used to what
comes with these big events
and a dress from school children
something a bit different
unlike most addresses
[Music]
and happy to accept more cards from a
local children's charity
thank you very much indeed
in her message to the nation she pledged
to keep serving her country and that
also means protecting the institution
now when it comes to the future she
could not have made her wishes any
clearer rhiannon mills sky news at
sandringham